you okay with covering for me now
absolutely i'm the principal of the
school i can answer a couple of calls
i'm probably gonna kick back and finish
my book you're okay
divorcee adventures in singlehood good
you're doing the work do you mind if i
take the keyboard cleaner i'm
really sweating it up helen are you
nervous
i am alpha you're gonna be fine i think
of old harold
sacramento all right wife left him when
he was 97 said he was too old
now he's out there dating having the
time of his life
or or maybe this was published in 2013
he's probably dead oh well now i'm
half nervous and half sad
congratulations ralph you
made me into an actual teen are you too
angsty to do a handshake with your
principal
never
we got this thank you bro
hey get going little missy the bell rang
10 minutes ago oh my god
out of my way boomer
she has a little white house replica
right inside of her door so anthony and
i
can plant the glitter bomb and retreat
very easily we just need
we need somebody to distract granny
shitbird we need the ultimate
distractor how about you sarika
you seem like you go into a lot of
stores and asked to speak to the manager
only the customer service is subpar you
asked to speak to my manager
it's called a hair net grace okay no but
we need a true distraction here
if it comes to it i'd be willing to show
my uh
kazoo you
no no come on no and please never tell
us what you're referring to
hey yo mr g what if it was this let's
say it's raining i've got my shirt open
of course
i walk up and i'm like maybe
i saw you at the movies girl
maybe i saw you at the car wash
i can't remember where i saw you girl
but i remember that i liked it girl
cancel the sectional that [ __ ] is gonna
need a coffin
very smooth very smooth high teeth sorry
i'm tardy oh
sonic my apologies mr bones
i mean i'm not sure if it's a mister but
i'm assuming it's hard to tell what
they're growing once the flesh is boiled
off
historically most of those are made from
male hobo bodies and you know the lady
hobos don't donate
their bodies as much isn't that a head
scratcher
anyway i don't mean to distract from the
learning
so uh take it away mr griffins yes
please continue the lesson mr griffins
as you can see i've drawn a popcorn
maker which is the perfect thing
to picture the orderly chaos within each
human cell and then we got talking about
a a biological phenomenon known as
distractors
oh it seems to uh i put my backpack i
took it off while i was sitting and it
somehow hooked to the top of my
undergrinders
it's just i just got to free myself from
this little trap here
you yow can you unzip that big zipper
back there but just do it real slow
otherwise i think i'm gonna launch into
the blackboard i'm basically a bullfrog
in a slingshot right now
oh god that hurts that is bad
you got pull no that's the wrong way
my pork tenderloin is i'm not gonna be
able to sit on a bar stool for like a
year
looks like we found our distractor i'm
just glued
i'm glued and i'm flossed
[Music]
you